rise and shine you've been asleep for
1,000 years
and the view outside is not how you
remembered it
[Music]
trees wildlife fresh air fresh water oh
oh right this is what if and here's what
would happen if everyone froze for 1,000
years rising temperatures rising sea
levels declining air quality more
extreme weather more animal extinctions
more diseases these are just a few of
the consequences we can expect if we
continue to pollute the earth and our
time to act is quickly running out so
what can we do if we want to save our
planet and fast strangely enough the
best thing to do might be nothing not
sit back and watch the world burn
nothing but everyone going to sleep and
doing nothing for 1,000 years while the
world repairs itself from all the damage
we've done we can pretty much guarantee
that earth will be better off but can we
guarantee that you'll wake up sweet
dreams there are almost 300
cryogenically frozen individuals in the
United States and 50 in Russia and yet
no one has ever been revived from cryo
sleep the hope is that the technology to
wake people up from cryo sleep will be
available sometime in the near future
the idea behind cryonics
is that humans can be preserved at super
low temperatures and later restored to
full health support for cryonics is
based on the fact that many living
things including human embryos can be
successfully cryopreserve and revived
existing cryopreservation techniques can
even preserve the fine structure of the
brain however we can't unfreeze a brain
and make it work again yet but suppose
we perfected the process and made it
possible to cryogenically preserve our
world's population of eight billion
people where would we put everybody the
most practical setup would be to have
cryo sleep chambers in big facilities
around the world this would make it
easier to respond to any technical
difficulties that might arise while also
protecting people from the inevitable
decay of our infrastructure but it's not
like every human-made structure would
fall apart and disappear because not
everyone would be asleep we need some
volunteers appointees or lucky winners
of a draw to keep everything running
smoothly
Australian geneticist Ian Franklin and
American biologist Michael Saleh
suggests that you need at least 500
people to maintain a stable population
with enough genetic variety but with
most of the world's population in
cryosleep our impact on the planet would
be rolled back global warming would
continue for another forty years after
we go to sleep but within a few decades
our homes would break down and within
100 years wood structures would be gone
and steel structures would begin to rust
our cities would start to fill with
plants trees and vines and new rivers
would form since subway tunnels would
flood without pumps working to keep the
water out after a few hundred years many
species of plants and animals would
bounce back to their original levels you
know before we evolved and took over the
planet
after 500 years the forests would be the
healthiest they've been in the last
10,000 years when we'd finally wake
1,000 years into the future we wouldn't
recognize the world outside the planet
would be lush and green but our homes
and most of our cities would be gone
there'd be lots of rebuilding to do
once everyone awakes but it wouldn't go
back to the way things were the whole
reason why the Earth's population went
into cryo sleep was to repair our planet
we'd likely put strict laws and policies
in place to ensure that our new way of
life doesn't waste our critical second
chance after all we'd still have some
poignant reminders of our toxic legacy
it would take more than 1,000 years for
our carbon dioxide levels to return to
normal
while radioactive material and
long-lasting organic chemicals could be
around for much longer
microplastics for example will still
exist hundreds of millions of years from
now unless we find a way to help them
decompose while sleeping off the effects
of climate change
sounds like a relatively easy way to
undo the damage we've caused to our
planet we probably won't have the
technology to do it any time soon but
can we really afford to wait the
consequences of climate change are
already causing major problems around
the world are you prepared for a lot
more extreme weather do you know how to
survive a tsunami or an earthquake
well we've got some tips for you on our
new show how to survive so be sure to
check it out and if you're looking for a
more hypothetical take on survival like
a timeline to human extinction well
that's a story for another what if
you